yes
nicole richie's 40th birthday was lit
no literally she accidentally set
herself on fire i'm just being me the
reality star posted this moment from her
milestone birthday on instagram blowing
out the candles on her cake when all of
a sudden her hair was ablaze
thankfully her friends and fam put out
the fire and no one was hurt and nicole
she fittingly wrote in the caption well
so far 40 is fire
naturally the comment section blew up
with comments from friends and fans
nick's hubby joel madden chimed in with
a pun that also happens to be a
signature nicole phrase
that's hot
while his twin brother benji madden
wrote
happy birthday sis love you and thankful
for you always stay lit i just kind of
try and find the humor in in everything
and that's how that's how i live my life
zoe deschanel kept it short and sweet
with three little letters omg
chelsea handler welcome to nicole to a
new decade of life adding that your 40s
are quote where the party really gets
started meanwhile queer eye's anthony
porowski was all of us quote i feel
awful for laughing i'm sorry also happy
birthday
doesn't it all feel like a scene out of
nicole and paris hilton's the simple
life that could be grounds for
termination what's termination fired
[Music]
last month it caught up with the house
of harlow designer who shares two kiddos
thirteen-year-old daughter harlow and
eleven-year-old son sparrow with her
rocker hubby and she dished on whether
she would let them be on reality tv
first of all there were only two reality
shows before then so it was
the osborne's and the real world and
that this show wasn't that so it was it
was a completely new concept altogether
we had no idea what we were getting
ourselves into or where we were going
but if my kids said to me i want to try
this new thing that hasn't been done
before you know you just you'd say
well obviously now they're they're
pre-teens so i'm gonna say no but yeah
if they're 18 and they want to go do
whatever it is
you know as long as it feels good and
and authentic to them i'm fine with it